how has the pandemic changed the film
business
great question very timely um
the major change is obviously the
theatrical
business you know theater's closing so
that's had a huge impact on how movies
are viewed now
especially you know the big blockbuster
tentpole releases
uh so that's a big one but
that also caused a huge change in in the
whole vod world like the streaming world
so all these studios that were probably
thinking about you know becoming
subscription video on demand services
had it in the
works likely accelerated their plans
and now all of a sudden you've got you
know eight or ten
major streaming services when before you
had
netflix really was it and then you know
an amazon prime
and then of course disney plus was
starting up but disney plus really
jumped in quickly
and then everybody followed so i think
that the studios realized they needed
another
you know avenue to to exhibit their
movies
because they couldn't depend on the
theaters obviously and
um you know that accelerated that so
much
and i'm not sure if it's good or bad i
think for indie films it's actually not
good which i'll talk about later
but probably for overall viewership for
for consumers
now there's such a vast choice of
quality programming
that's available at really affordable
prices so i guess that's good
now me personally i love going to the
movies like i like a night out at the
movie theater
i love watching you know a big movie on
in a big format on a huge screen with a
great sound system you know in a very
confined
you know like dark room like that so i
for one will be back at the movies the
minute they start up
i mean because i it's a night out for my
wife and i i love
watching a movie that way hopefully a
lot of people are thinking like me and
can't wait to get
back to the movies but you know a lot of
people went out and bought really big
you know flat screen tvs and good sound
systems and
you know and i i did too and i enjoy
that
it's been a great way to watch you know
content in the comfort of your own home
but i i believe that the theatrical
business will be back
and it will be healthy and robust and
just because
human beings need to go out and need to
socialize
and and that's a night out do you think
things will be totally the same as they
were let's say 2019
right right toward december of 2019
once things start to open up i know
we're on the eve of it
as of this interview but do you think
things will be returned to that exact
level
or there will be changes yeah i mean
it's all driven obviously by the the
major studios
because they have the big programming
that people want to see so
i don't know just because there's going
to be a decision made corporately in in
each of their
boardrooms and they're going to say hey
let's do the math on this
if we open you know theatrically for six
to eight weeks
pre vod what will the numbers look like
if we go day and date what will the
numbers look like i mean it's all about
numbers right i mean they're in business
to make money
and they got to decide what is the best
way to
you know to cater to their audience so
that they can make the revenue they want
to make
so i i really don't know um i know the
theaters
i don't know for sure but what i've read
is the theaters obviously are going to
want an exclusive
window you know pre the vod release
but maybe the studios have
learned something new that may carry on
and frankly i mean as a consumer that's
not going to matter to me
i don't really care whether there's a
date vod release with the theatrical
release i'll still go to the movie
theater
to see the movie because i want to see
it that way and i will pay my 15
and buy my popcorn and everything
because i want to go out i mean i want
to i want to watch those big movies that
way
so even if they're offered at the same
time you know on vod
i'm still not going i'd rather consume
it that way now if they're not
and that's a way to get subscribers by
offering them day and date that's a
corporate decision
and you know i'll understand but i don't
know movie theaters so if i did i
wouldn't understand
how has the pandemic changed your
company and you as a filmmaker
that's a great question well my company
did not make a movie in 2020 we were
supposed to
i have a great other new sports drama
that i was hoping to shoot
and i've already kind of almost set up
pre-distribution for it so i was really
excited about it
and but the pandemic slowed that down
because the protocols for shooting were
very very restrictive and plus
personally i
don't really want to do that i mean i
don't i didn't want to put my own health
at risk i didn't want to put
the crew or the cast or anybody at risk
so i didn't feel it was worth it to
to have to shoot during the pandemic and
it's still in
you know it's still sort of waiting um
i'm hoping maybe we could shoot this
fall
but uh we have to see how that all plays
out but um i'm respectful of the fact
that hey
it's a pandemic crazy thing crazy year
crazy
almost year and a half now by the time
this is over
um but it happens and you know
we'll get through it and we'll see what
looks like on the other end
so i'm anxious to to shoot a game but i
didn't want to shoot
during the pandemic which meant i had
like you know
a year more little more than a year to
do other stuff
so that actually was interesting and
you know at first i was kind of
disappointed but then i said let's
make you know lemons into lemonade here
so i did two things one is i stepped up
my consulting practice quite a bit
so i do a lot more consulting with indie
filmmakers
and you know i'm enjoying that because
everybody is kind of struggling and
going through the same thing and it's
nice to
chat with people and give them advice
and i think i've
connected with a lot of filmmakers and i
feel like they've learned a lot and
i've hopefully helped them through stuff
and i'm sure some of them will be
watching this interview and
hopefully make nice comments but also i
started teaching too
so i live in san diego i teach at san
diego state university and i teach in
the film production department
but i teach the business aspects of
indie filmmaking
so it's primarily distribution and
finance
which are the boring parts of the film
business you know the students want to
learn about
camera and lighting acting directing
editing all that kind of stuff
you know film making right production
so they have to take my course to
graduate if you're
if you're a film major and they learn
about
finance and distribution primarily a
little bit about budgeting and
scheduling
and so it's been interesting because at
first the students are you know
a little leery of it you know because
they don't realize
what that entails but i've really gotten
great feedback on that from all the
students who are taking my course and
they're primarily upper level students
because they didn't really understand
distribution at all i mean they've heard
the word but they had no clue what it is
i talk a lot about marketing and you
know how to
kind of make sure that you've got your
plans in place before you start shooting
so that
maybe you'll do things differently
during your shoot if you need to
um and you know the whole financing
piece everybody's really curious about
how that is
all gets put together there's legal
terms technical terms lots of business
terms which yeah
people who are artists and filmmakers
don't really love that
but totally appreciate it once they
understand how it all fits together
to become you know the film business and
so
in my course i call it the business of
film um
the students call it the film business i
always say you should put the business
part first
not the film part but you know they're
both equal i mean you need to have the
art obviously the artistic side but
they're taking
you know a dozen courses on that side
and one course in business and you know
maybe that will expand into more
i believe in order to be a successful
filmmaker as i've said many times
in your interviews and to other people
it's really helpful to know
what really goes on on the business side
primarily the distribution side
you don't have to do it all and i tell
people you don't have to become an
expert in it but
it's good to understand it to at least
be aware what goes on what other people
do
so that you you know you can be part of
the conversation and the narrative and
and just be a little bit more up to
speed
so that when you do cross those bridges
at least you know what the bridge is
what do you start out with once you get
through all of sort of the the
housekeeping of the
of the course and and the timeline and
what materials they need
what do you start with so it's
interesting um so i teach
in my course which is the business
aspects of filmmaking i teach three
units
i teach distribution production and
finance
and i actually teach them in that order
so inevitably the first question i get
asked is
why are you teaching distribution before
you teach production like shouldn't you
be teaching you know
all the legal and business aspects of
making a movie which is production
before you teach selling a movie or how
about you shouldn't you teach financing
a movie before you teach
selling or making a movie but i chose
those
that that order on purpose because i
said
in order to be a successful filmmaker
because i you know i teach about sort of
commercially viable
filmmaking obviously you have to be a
good artist you have to make a good film
you can't sell a bad film so i take for
granted i say
i assume you're going to make a good
film that's what the other teachers are
teaching
at you how to make a great film so i'll
check that box
but before you make that great film you
really need to understand
you know three major things who your
audience is who you're making it for
you know how you're going to create
awareness with that audience and will
your audience pay to consume it
if you want to make money with your
movies and that's all distribution
so it's really important to understand
those components
before you make your film because one is
you might make a different film two is
you might not make the film you're
making i mean
if you really want to look at the
business component so that like at the
end you don't struggle and say
oh if i only would have known or if i
had a thought of that first
that's why i teach distribution first
because distribution really is
enlightening
to understand sort of the film that
you're crafting so that you make the
right film so you could sell it
afterwards
and and even while you're making it you
have to understand distribution so that
maybe you have you're making components
that help you market the film
or maybe even doing social media from
set or that type of thing
you're marketing marketing marketing
preparing to sell your film before you
make it
have you been surprised by any of the
questions or actually
just pleasantly sort of enlightened by
how
advanced some of these individuals are
when it comes to distribution
yeah well no i mean all i'm going to say
ninety-nine i say probably 100 of
students who go to film school
go to learn production i mean that's
what film school is teaching you how to
make
a movie i think our school
san diego state university you know
recognized that it's really important
to teach distribution of finance because
those are such important components of
being a successful career filmmaker
but for the most part students don't
expect to learn about those kind of
things because those are sort of the
business things and film schools about
the artistic things
so at first i'm not surprised they're
surprised the students are surprised
when they take the course they have to
take my course to graduate if you're a
film major so it's a prereq
you know there's two prerequisites and
you know and it's a mandatory course
so you know i'm the course they don't
want to take because it's all the boring
stuff
it's legal business stuff that type of
thing but once they do take it
and they start understanding about you
know how distribution works and what the
different platforms are and how they buy
and
sell and and how movies you know get
financed and this kind of thing they're
totally intrigued by it
they're probably a little overwhelmed by
it as well
because there's so much that they
haven't really thought about
you know financing a movie is in my
estimation
far more complicated than making the
movie or editing it
um like i say everything's important i'm
not belittling any
everything anything but um to understand
you know how the whole system works from
start to finish
as a business is fascinating for them
and and they're learning a lot they're
learning things that they had no idea
they were going to learn about so i'm
really happy
with how much they're being exposed to
and learning but they're also there's
lots and lots of questions because once
you learn a little bit
you want to kind of learn more and
there's just not enough time to answer
it all as a matter of fact i've had to
cut my materials in half twice
because there's just so much to teach
and and i take for granted
because i know it all you know that they
can i can go quicker but
but i have to go a little slower because
you know i just throw around terms you
know like
like vod a v o d t v o d s v o d like
you know no big deal right like that's
if you're in the
movie business you know about that you
don't know about that
if you're a film student you don't know
what those platforms are you've heard of
netflix you know you've heard of disney
plus you've heard of some of these
things but
you don't necessarily know what all
these things are so i have to really
take time to explain all that kind of
stuff and it's important because now
they have a very good handle
on potentially where the movies they're
gonna make are gonna go
and of course it's gonna change you know
probably changes all the time but for
now
you